you know having the right information
for various health conditions especially
a stroke
um could be the difference between you
having a full recovery and not having
any recovery so today I'm going to show
you some really important information on
what to do if you have a stroke as far
as what nutrient to take as well as the
best nutrient to recover from a stroke
if you get one now you have many strokes
and then you have severe Strokes the
mini strokes can last anywhere between
15 minutes to 24 hours and the symptoms
are not permanent they go away but then
you have a severe stroke which can leave
permanent damage on one side of your
body and if you get a mini stroke the
odds of you getting a severe stroke are
pretty high it's like one in five within
the next year so it's definitely a big
clue that you better change things
really quick and this video is going to
be very important if you've ever had a
mini stroke now there's a very simple
way to identify various indicators that
you're having a stroke and the acronym
is be fast and b stands for balance
let's say your balance is off you're not
coordinated so that's B and then e
that's for I so maybe one of your eyes
gets blurry all right F is for face so
one side of your face starts drooping
and you can identify this if you smile
then you have a for on so one of your
arms just does not want to go up and
then s for speech your speech is a
little bit slurred and then T basically
for time because you want to call an
ambulance really fast there's a certain
drug that they give you if you catch it
under four hours to help dissolve the
clot so what is this nutrient that's so
important well it's a type of vitamin E
but it's not the regular vitamin E that
you might have heard of like tocopherol
it's a different type of vitamin E
called tocatrino and each type of
vitamin E has their own subtype so you
have like Alpha the beta the gamma the
Delta for each type of vitamin E and the
alpha tocotrino is a thousand times
stronger than the alpha tocopherol in
protecting the neural degeneration that
occurs from a stroke and all it takes is
extremely small doses to prevent a
glutamate induced brain cell death so
let's say for example you start noticing
you have a problem with your speech or
your arm or you're getting a stroke then
you'd want to take this tocotranol
immediately to prevent more damage but
even if you don't have any tocotrino on
hand I would go out to get some and use
that in your rehab for a stroke and
whatever it recommends on the directions
I would take probably four times that
and I would spread it out through the
day and I would not take it with
tocopherolsk I would only take
tocatrinols in a blend that includes the
alpha the beta the gamma and the Delta
because apparently the decofalo all and
the tokatrinos tend to compete and we
don't want anything to dilute the effect
so tocotrinos can be used to prevent a
stroke to help during the stroke
preventing damage and in the recovery
phase after you get a stroke the
tocatrinals have very special properties
protecting the cell membrane of a neuron
so it's also good for other things like
Alzheimer's
Parkinson's dystonia which is this
involuntary movement or twisting motion
it's also very beneficial for Ataxia
which is this condition where you are
very uncoordinated your balance is is
terrible and you're falling and you just
don't have the balance because there's
some type of damage in the back part of
the brain called the cerebellum and it's
also good for another condition called
dis autonomia okay so basically that's a
dysfunction of your autonomic nervous
system the sympathetic and the
parasympathetic if there's one of these
two systems that are working in
overdrive or not working strong enough
vitamin E is what you should take so one
example would be let's say you um you
just can't sweat no matter how much
exercise you do another opposite
condition would be you just sweat all
the time and you you can't control it
that would be an example of dysautonomia
another condition would be called pots
okay that's a condition where you can't
even stand up without you know passing
out it's a severe problem with the
autonomic nervous system and I've talked
about that in a lot of videos B1 is very
very important but also vitamin E in the
form of tocotrenals and one last thing
that tocotrinos are really good for has
nothing to do with the brain it has
everything to do with the heart okay as
in like a heart attack so you can look
at tocotrinals as a natural version of
nitroglycerin because it's very powerful
in increasing the oxygen to the heart
muscle itself now vitamin E in general
is necessary to allow the omega-3 fats
especially DHA to work in the brain so
if you're deficient in vitamin E you
could be taking a lot of fish oils and
DHA directly and not notice a lot of
change one of the biggest reasons why
people are deficient in vitamin E is
they consume too many refined grains so
refined grains are a big reason why you
might be deficient in vitamin E or it
could be you're just not consuming
enough foods that are high in vitamin E
now we talk about tocotranos it's a bit
difficult to get it from Foods because
I'll just list the foods that it's in a
Neto which you've probably never heard
of then we have palm oil well a lot of
people don't consume palm oil it's also
in rice bran oil okay which a lot of
people don't consume that but it's also
in olive oil in very small amounts out
of all the conditions that you can get
you don't want to get a stroke and so
how do you prevent it do you just take
an aspirin a day well you should check
with your doctor with that but there's
some recent information about aspirin
that could be damaging especially if you
have a hemorrhage type stroke where
there's a bursted blood vessel and then
you take an aspirin and it causes more
bleeding in your stomach and other parts
of the body I'm not telling you not to
take your aspirin but just check with
your doctor and then get the full
information on if you should take it or
not but there's some natural things to
thin the blood like garlic that's one
being on the ketogenic diet and getting
the sugars out of the diet which is one
of the deeper causes for a clot or a
plaquing or the formation of a plaque
omega-3 fatty acids okay fish oils very
important cod liver oil is really good
as well as well as getting rid of the
omega-6 fatty acids which is in a lot of
restaurant foods and it's hidden in the
soil oil and the corn oil and the canola
oil in the safflower oil the sunflower
oil so they can create inflammation in
the arteries and potentially cause a
problem with the stroke down the road
and regular exercise to keep the blood
flow and to actually decrease your risk
of stroke but if you ever experience any
symptoms of a stroke where you know
someone that had a stroke get them on
the tocatranal version of vitamin E now
if you haven't seen my other video on
top katrinos I'm going to put that up
right here check it out